it was revealed some months ago that the
national institute of allergy and
infectious disease under the leadership
of anthropology spent hundreds of
thousands of dollars funding experiments
in which aborted babies at 20 weeks
gestation were chopped into pieces and
little bits of them were then grafted
onto rodents to create as it is
described by the researchers humanized
mice
this really happened uh the mice with
baby scalps attached to them were
monitored for weeks in an effort to
learn more about infectious diseases and
cancer and whatever else
now there's very good chance that you
never heard about those experiments at
all but whether you did or didn't it can
it can be said that there was little
public outcry over it there was no
public outcry there was certainly no
bipartisan outrage about it
just as there's been um
no bipartisan outrage there's been
outrage but no bipartisan outrage over
the fact that fauci's nih funded virus
research in wuhan something that the
national institute of health
finally admitted this week after months
of denial from fouchy personally
in front of congress in many sessions
arguing back and forth with uh with rand
paul
saying this didn't happen now they admit
that it did that's to say nothing of
fouchy's incompetence indifference and
political gamesmanship during the
pandemic the pandemic that his
institution may partially be responsible
for in the first place
i mean overall fauci has shown an
utterly callous disregard
for human life and human suffering he
has special contempt for life at its
most vulnerable stages in the womb which
is also why he went running to the world
health organization a day after biden's
inauguration to triumphantly announce
that the mexico city policy banning
funding of abortion overseas would be
lifted i mean he couldn't wait for that
to happen
this is the kind of man that fouchy is
a soulless bureaucrat a shill
who feels no guilt for the blood on his
hands and there's a substantial amount
of human blood on his hands
but in spite of the moral crimes i just
listed and perhaps partially because of
them
fauci has been as you've noticed
not only led off the hook but hailed as
a hero much like andrew cuomo was in the
early months of the pandemic you recall
that cuomo was so widely acclaimed that
people on the left were proudly
declaring themselves homosexual
even as the then governor consigned
thousands of elderly people to their
deaths by locking them in nursing homes
with coveted positive patients
that didn't hurt his reputation at all
until it came out that cuomo along with
being a serial killer of the elderly
also made inappropriate comments to
women
you know the mass graves of grandmas and
grandpas those were tolerable but
flirtatious remarks to women were not
and so cuomo was summarily knocked off
of his perch and then right out of the
governor's mansion
perhaps fauci may face a similar fate as
this week for the first time in his
career
he's been the target of negative
headlines in the corporate media and
we're told bipartisan outrage
not because little babies were chopped
into pieces and stitched onto rats
not because the nih funded research in
wuhan not because of the thousands dead
due to incompetence and malice from our
public health expert class
including fauci
but
because some dogs were mistreated
here's our local fox 17 in nashville
with the story it says a tennessee
congressman is among 23 other federal
lawmakers bipartisan group to sign a
letter calling on dr anthony fauci and
the national institutes of health to
respond to reports on the testing and
killing of puppies in the name of
science
the issue centers around a report from
the animal advocacy group and taxpayer
watchdog white coat waste project which
has previously reported on puppy testing
specifically beagles
wcwp reports this is the fourth time
they've uncovered inhumane practices on
beagle puppies funded by the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases a part of the nih which dr
faushi heads the report states that the
niaid
spent 1.6 million dollars in taxpayer
funds to poison and debark
44 beagle puppies force-feeding the
puppies an experimental drug cutting
their vocal cords
and then killing and dissecting them the
cutting of the vocal cords known as
debarking as opposed by the humane
society of the united states and the
american veterinary medical association
or a procedure that the wcwp calls a
pain painful and cruel adding that their
fundings were a result of a freedom of
their findings rather a result of a
freedom of information act request
saying the studies on beagles were
unnecessary as the drug being studied
had already been extensively tested and
confirmed on different animals
okay and peta has of course come out
strongly as expected as well even though
peta kills dogs all the time so they
shouldn't have an issue here
as mentioned the lawmakers demanding
answers from voucher are bipartisan
marking the first time that the phrase
bipartisan lawmakers and demand answers
from fauci can be used in a sentence
together
in another first there have been actual
critical headlines about voucher in
mainstream news sites
and the criticism is warranted
of course
it sounds like the beagle experiments
were unnecessary and cruel
even if the ultimate goal was to develop
medical treatments that might benefit
human beings
i mean i would rather if you got to test
this stuff i'd rather be tested on
animals not people
but
even so
sounds like it's a very cruel and
terrible experiment
and yet
dogs are not people
puppies are not babies
not human babies anyway
there is nothing you could do to a puppy
that would be worse than scalping an
infant
which is what they did in those other
experiments that nobody cared about
they scalped infants
now i am welcoming of an
of any warranted criticism fauci
receives
and if this is ultimately the thing that
leads to him to resign in disgrace much
like cuomo i don't know if that'll
happen or not
but if it does i'll be happy to see him
go
but at a certain point we have to stand
back and and assess our priorities
and figure out how we ended up in a
culture where tortured puppies attract
more outrage than tortured babies
i mean this isn't this is not a what
about thing
it's not what about isn't because i'm
not trying
to change the subject from from uh from
these experiments what i'm trying to do
is talk about priorities
and the fact that we
and i speak in general terms when i say
we
value the lives of dogs over the lives
of our fellow human beings
we practice the weirdest form of pagan
animal worship
in this country that the world has ever
seen
it's not based in mythology like other
cultures unless we count all the
anthropomorphizing disney movies that we
grew up watching and i do think actually
that has something to do with it
um and there are no standard religious
practices surrounding it
we've come to our animal worship not
from a position of religious fervor
necessarily but more from a place of
despair and indifference
we don't recognize the inherent worth
and dignity in human beings anymore
so we've elevated dogs to take that
place instead
this is something so pervasive
that you hear it even from conservatives
this unfortunately i wish i could say
this is a left versus right this is
another left versus right um uh paradigm
here but it's not
i hear from self-professed conservatives
all the time saying in fact proudly
saying openly saying yeah i i i value
dogs more than people i care about my
dog more than i care about most people
this is
and you're a conservative
saying that you value human life below
dogs and you think that that you can
qualify as a conservative what exactly
do you think you're conserving here
i thought one of the most fundamental
things we're conserving is the dignity
and moral worth of human life
and if you're putting dogs above people
then you're not conserving that
and you're not on my side
i don't know whose side you think you're
on
and this is something we don't want to
talk about this it's something nobody
wants to talk about i mean i've been
talking about it for for years
there is something and i know it's
difficult for a lot of people
because our because of our attachment to
dogs and no one is saying that we
shouldn't have pet dogs as pets or we
shouldn't care about our dogs
but if you notice something within
yourself where you value the lives of
dogs over people
then that is a deep sickness in your
soul
that you need to try to fix
because
this this we cannot have a society like
this
where this even needs to be a discussion
where it can come out that they were
chopping babies into pieces
and nobody cares until they say oh yeah
they also did it to dogs
[Music]
our priorities
are massively out of a line
and we need to get them straight if you
enjoyed this video be sure to give it a
thumbs up and share it with all your
friends